j'ouvre notre second débat débat de
société là aussi consacrée à la pénurie
de médicaments en France le phénomène
s'est déclenché vous le savez avec la
crise covid aggravée depuis au point que
45% des personnes pour cent des
personnes touchées par une pénurie de
médicaments ont du modifier leur
traitement où il renoncer pour faire
face certains professionnels de santé
s'organise comme cette pharmacie qui
produit elle-même le principal
antibiotique l'amoxicilline Samia de
chir et Erwan Douillac bon Jeannot
vous avez fait le bon diagnostic un jean
il y a un vrai œdème d'une certaine
manière ce patient a de la chance les
médicaments qui lui faut sont
disponibles en pharmacie ceux qui ont
besoin d'amoxicilline devront sans doute
courir d'une officine à l'autre pour
espérer en trouver depuis décembre
dernier la France connaît une pénurie de
cet antibiotique couramment utilisé pour
soigner angine bronchite et autres
infections quand il le peut ce médecin
propose un traitement alternatif dans la
plupart des cas on peut substituer même
si on est moins content même si on est
moins ciblé par rapport à la pathologie
mais on arrive à substituer mais c'est
quand même tout à fait désagréable
d'abord pour le patient d'avoir besoin
de courir les pharmacies et ensuite pour
nous d'avoir besoin de réviser notre
traitement pour donner un traitement
moins spécifique moins adapté
la pénurie d'amoxicilline les autorités
ont fait appel aux pharmacies équipées
d'un département préparatoire la France
en compte une quarantaine comme cette
officine parisienne qui produit jusqu'à
15 000 gélules d'amoxicilline par jour
minutieusement pesée et conditionné
entièrement à la main ces préparations
là elles vont partir on va les étiqueter
et elles vont partir
donc là dans chaque petit pot on a 15
gélules d'amoxicilline à 250 mg ces
boîtes sont destinées aux quelques 6500
pharmacies clientes de l'officine qui
passe commande chaque soir au
compte-goutte en fonction des demandes
un traitement est vendu 23 € contre une
dizaine d'euros pour les boîtes de
l'industrie pharmaceutique ici une
pharmacie qui se trouve à
Vigneux-sur-Seine qui a besoin de 15
boîtes donc voilà si une cliente qui est
à saint-paul-sur-mer qui demande 10
boîtes donc dans différents dosages en
125 en 250 ou en 500 mg jusqu'ici les 40
pharmacies préparatoires de France
n'avaient jamais fabriqué d'amoxicilline
depuis le 28 décembre elle se coordonne
chaque jour en lien avec les autorités
sanitaires la première semaine d'avril a
été une très très grosse semaine
et on a fait à peu près vous voyez
presque 200 000 gélules la semaine
dernière on est capable de faire très
vite une grosse production en attendant
que l'industrie pharmaceutique soit
capable de revenir la question
aujourd'hui qu'on se pose effectivement
c'est comment se fait-il que on est
encore autant de demandes alors que
normalement
l'industrie aurait dû reprendre le
relais surtout que le mois d'avril et
pas le mois le plus important en termes
de demande d'amoxicilline l'industrie
pharmaceutique est capable de fabriquer
en très grande quantité à des prix moins
élevés mais une fois qu'une chaîne de
production est arrêtée la relance s'est
prend du temps la force des pharmacies
c'est justement leur agilité du jour au
lendemain elles ont été capables de
prendre le relais des industriels il y a
40 sous-traitants on arrive à faire
quand même une grosse production et si
on était 400 par exemple comme en
Espagne et aussi le mettez 2000
pharmaciens à continuer à produire en
cas de pénurie en réalité il y aurait
plus de pénurie en France on est on
serait capable de produire le
paracétamol on serait capable de
produire les antibiotiques on serait
capable de produire les corticoïdes
puisque les corticoïdes il y a une très
grosse demande aussi en ce moment en
France la production de médicaments en
pharmacie a peu à peu disparu en raison
d'une législation contraignante et d'une
main d'oeuvre difficile à trouver les
pharmaciens préfèrent désormais
sous-traitées
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités pour ce second débat Sonia de la
propreté bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénatrice centriste du Calvados si
vous présidez à commission d'enquête
senatoriale sur cette pénurie de
médicaments et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique françaises Frédéric
bizarres bonsoir bienvenue à vous
économiste spécialiste des questions de
protection sociale et de santé vous êtes
professeur d'économie affilié à l'escpe
Europe et ce livre auteur de l'autonomie
solidaire en santé la seule réforme
possible publiée aux éditions michalonge
accueille également Philippe Lamoureux
bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
directeur général du lems et
l'organisation professionnelle des
entreprises du médicament et Mathieu
croissanto évidemment est resté à mes
côtés Sonia de la pauvreté vous aviez
visité cette cette pharmacie avec avec
la dans le cadre de cette commission
d'enquête il y en a beaucoup dans le
même cas là qui qui produisent leur
propre médicament est-ce que ça vous
semble une solution
c'est une solution pour pallier les
carences au moment où il y a un vrai
sujet et là en l'occurrence avec la
triple épidémie il y avait plus
d'amoxicilline et on a quand même cette
force en France avoir un réseau de
pharmacie partout sur le territoire mais
aussi d'avoir des des pharmaciens qui
sont en capacité de produire alors ils
produisent pas le principe actif il se
fournissent en amoxicilline à
l'extérieur mais il fabrique les gélules
c'est ce qu'on appelle les préparations
officinales magistrales mais ça permet
quand même de de régler la question un
provisoirement ce dont je m'étonne à
l'instar du pharmacien c'est que
effectivement on est plus tout à fait
normalement en pénurie et c'est vrai que
ça traite ça traîne beaucoup et il est
encore obligé de fournir mais mais eux
ils font 15000 gélules par jour jusqu'à
15000 par jour ça fait un traitement de
5 jours pour 1000 passions donc c'est
quand même pas négligeable et donc ils
sont une quarantaine en France à le
faire et ce réseau peut être activé si
nécessaire ils peuvent tout préparé mais
au moins quelques médicaments essentiels
vous pouvez sûrement répondre à la
question de ce de ce pharmacien et de la
sénatrice pour pourquoi il y a encore
une autant de tension sur ce cet
antibiotique précisément alors il y a eu
il y a eu cet automne une conjonction
assez assez inédite avec une forte
prévalence de du covid toujours une
épidémie de grippe et une épidémie de
pathologie respiratoire donc on a été
plutôt évidemment
une année très hautes très haute
intensité et un appareil de production
qui s'est remis en production comme ça a
été dit avec on sortait de la période
covid ou la consommation de ce type de
produit avait été assez faible donc il a
fallu ajuster ça a pris un petit peu de
temps ce que montre très bien se
reportage en avril il y a plus dans
cette épidémie sur des sujets le flux de
production de la boxicilline va
reprendre normalement ce qui est
intéressant de ce reportage c'est qu'on
voit bien que c'est une solution
palliative mais ça ne se substitue pas
évidemment à la production industrielle
et l'autre élément qui était intéressant
et votre reporter à très bien montré
c'est que les coûts et les prix de
fabrication ne sont pas du tout les
mêmes et que entre 10 euros sortis
officines et 23 euros en coût de
fabrication c'est pas du tout la même
chose pour l'assurance maladie et donc
il y a des enjeux économiques très
importants c'est qu'il ne faut pas
oublier c'est bizarre est-ce qu'on
pourrait c'est ce que propose le
pharmacien d'entreportage finalement
démultiplier cette solution et jusqu'à
quel point ça fait quand même un peu
bricolage pour un pays comme la France
non peut-être d'abord s'il y avait des
problèmes sur l'amoxicilline et le
paracétamol je pense que vous feriez pas
cette émission
aux autres médicaments
conjoncturels il y a eu un choc d'offre
pendant le covid puis un choc de demande
à la sortie du covid donc on se retrouve
tendu bon tout ça fait partie du
business mais les causes sont beaucoup
plus profondes ça fait plus d'une
dizaine d'années que les Français
subissent à peu près un quart des
Français d'après les sondages subissent
des pénuries de médicaments donc il a
bien avoir des causes qui vont au delà
des aspects conjoncturels du covid la
première cause si on part de très loin
c'est l'ultra financiarisation de
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui fait que
l'industrie a quasiment totalement
délocalisé dans les pays à bas coût la
production de principes actifs
essentiellement même si on y est revenu
depuis trois quatre ans c'est une
logique économique pour maximiser le
profit vous allez là où les coûts sont
les plus bas bon le seul problème
donc après est-ce qu'on peut réguler ça
c'est compliqué à l'échelle d'un pays
parce que c'est une industrie
mondialisée mais c'est un sujet quand
certains sont pour un pôle
pharmaceutique public c'est c'est la
solution extrême mais l'intérêt dans Ça
c'est de se dire est-ce qu'on peut quand
même garder un contrôle sur la
production pharmaceutique qui est
financée à plus de 70% par des fonds
publics et qui représente un service
public absolument crucial pour la santé
des Français c'est ça le truc
l'autre point sur dans le dans les
causes profondes c'est la compétitivité
de notre pays on va prendre la
compétitivité prix il y a une commission
au Sénat mais je vois que cette question
par exemple elle est pas sur la table
c'est que pourquoi est-ce qu'on se
retrouve avec des prix nettement plus
faibles et quelquefois plus faible que
les couteaux de production en France
mais parce que depuis 2007 à peu près on
a une régulation comptable à l'aveugle
où on a fait du médicament une variable
d'ajustement pris pour garantir le
respect d'un d'une hausse du budget des
dépenses de santé donc on sabre 800
millions à 1 milliard par an alors
pourquoi pas le problème c'est que c'est
fait à l'aveugle c'est fait complètement
de façon déconnectée de toute politique
de santé publique et déconnecter d'une
réalité économique mais donc on se
retrouve avec un pays qui est très peu
attractif pour s'élaboratoires je vais
être à la meilleure on y reviendra sur
les prix c'est vraiment je vous propose
d'y revenir un petit peu plus tard
Mathieu voulait intervenir alors on y
revient c'est sympa Mathieu merci on y
reviendra ce que je voudrais qu'on reste
dans le constat de la de la pénurie
effectivement il y a pas que
l'amoxicilline le paracétamol on est
bien d'accord regardez les signalements
de rupture de stock ou de risque de
rupture reçues par l'agence nationale
sécurité du médicament on était à 400 et
quelques en 2016 et ça rejoint ce que
vous disiez avec bizarre et puis il y a
une progression constante ensuite il y a
l'année covid on passe à 2000 près de
2500 2020 ça baisse un peu en 2021 et là
on est à une estimation sur les derniers
chiffres qu'on a eu de 3000 signalements
la pauvreté c'est ces chiffres c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles vous avez
créé cette commission d'enquête pourquoi
c'est pourquoi cet aggravation pourquoi
voilà il y a eu la guerre en Ukraine je
sais bien que ça fait partie aussi des
des causes peut-être conjoncturelles
mais pourquoi cette aggravation comment
vous l'expliquez c'est multifactoriels
comme ça vient justement d'être dit à la
fois lié au prix du médicament en France
et aux politiques de remboursement du
médicament lié à le caractère
international de la chaîne du médicament
en conjoncturel on a évidemment le coût
de l'énergie les pénuries en matière de
carton de verre tout ce qui est
contenants qui sont quand même
nécessaires à la dispensation on a aussi
des monopoles sur la production certains
principes et puis on a une baisse de
souveraineté nationale en matière de
production notamment dans le domaine de
la chimie parce que on sait on a des
faces des façonniers comme on dit qui
savent
fabriquer le comprimé quand c'est
relativement simple et puis aller
jusqu'à l'étape du carton mais enfin de
la boîte mais pour ce qui est du
principe actif des et de la chimie on a
pu les savoir-faire dans le tropique
donc tout ça tout ça mis bout à bout
plus la conjoncture de la triple
épidémie comme ça vient d'être dit
justement fait que on est dans une
situation qui s'aggrave alors pourquoi
on a fait la Commission dans la
construction d'enquête a été décidé
parce qu'il y a eu un premier rapport
auquel j'avais participé avec la
rapporteur Laurence Cohen en juillet
2018 concernant la pénurie de
médicaments et de vaccins du Sénat qui
avait listé un certain nombre de sujets
et de conclusions donc je je vous
propose d'ailleurs de vous rapporter à
ce rapport qui s'était déjà la question
du prix du médicament et des politiques
de remboursement et de financement de la
santé en France qui sont effectivement
un des éléments limitants et un des
facteurs aggravants de la pénurie et
donc à l'époque il y avait déjà 700
médicaments en pénurie et là ce sont les
mêmes et c'est pire c'est à dire qu'on
est passé à 3000 c'est-à-dire que les
conclusions que nous avions il a pas été
il a pas été lu ça veut dire qu'il y a
eu entre temps alors il a été lu il n'a
pas été suivi d'effet en même temps
construit pas forcément toute une chaîne
de production industrielle du médicament
l'espace de 5 ans on sait bien que là on
part de loin quand même ce qui s'est
passé entre temps c'est qu'il y a eu de
la covid également mais la covid a eu un
élément positif c'est que nous avions
déjà évoqué la question européenne sur
ces sujets de de d'équilibre et de
traitement des questions d'accès aux
médicaments
et l'Europe a montré qu'elle était en
capacité de réagir en urgence et donc
pour le coup elle ne devient plus un
acteur anecdotique ou un acteur d'excuse
mais un acteur majeur potentiel
du traitement de la question des
pénuries de médicaments on va parler du
prix comme promis maintenant et on va y
consacrer vraiment un chapitre je
propose à mathiasarès de nous rejoindre
parce qu'on va essayer de se comparer un
peu à d'autres pays d'Europe et on va
commencer en faisant un constat un peu
similaire à celui de nos invités Mathias
reçois sur le l'aspect et c'est votre
chronique vous l'avez construite sur la
base des de certaines des auditions de
la commission d'enquête cette idée d'un
d'une de multiples causes c'est ce qu'on
retrouve un peu partout c'est ça
évidemment trop simpliste de penser
qu'une seule cause peut être à l'origine
des problèmes que rencontre actuellement
la France et pas seulement la France
d'ailleurs en matière
d'approvisionnement en médicaments ont
été évoqués parmi pendant ces auditions
les maillons défaillants sur la chaîne
industrielle depuis la crise du covid 19
une surconsommation également de
certains médicaments la hausse des prix
de l'énergie et son impact sur la
production bref des pénuries multi
factorielles comme le défend Thomas
Fatton directeur général de podcast
national de l'Assurance Maladie ces
pénuries répondent à la logique de
problèmes de matières premières de
problèmes de production industrie de
problèmes de quand la Chine est l'Inde
ont des problèmes quand ils ont des des
surconsommation voilà et que c'est un
phénomène pardon de manière comme ça
planétaire et donc on veut pas dire
c'est parce que la France a des prix
plus bas que les autres pays qu'on a un
problème massif de pénurie je crois pas
que ça soit la principale réponse je
prends un exemple très clair là aussi
Céline la motoxicilline le prix en
France il est deux fois plus élevé qu'en
Espagne et qu'au Royaume-Uni
deux fois plus élevé en UCD
alors que nous avons connu des pénuries
alors que les prix trop bas c'est
justement l'argument que d'autres nous
sortent c'est la version soutenue par
les laboratoires par des membres de
l'Académie de médecine ou encore les
pharmaciens selon eux les médicaments
dont on manque le plus se dit mature
sont achetés en dessous du prix de
revient ce qui incite pas les
industriels à livrer en priorité la
France comme l'explique Patrick l'église
pharmacien hospitalier auditionnée par
la commission d'enquête on a vu que les
que certains pays ont augmenté leur prix
oui c'est-à-dire que ben on augmente nos
offres de prix pour pour avoir plus pour
pour
être prioritaire sur les sur les
livraisons donc
nous sauvera de ma part je crois que le
Portugal avait rehaussé ses prix et je
crois que l'Allemagne aussi a fait la
même chose et hop comme par hasard ils
ont il y a pas eu beaucoup moins de
tension que qu'en France
voilà là encore tout le monde n'est pas
de cet avis non mercredi 29 mars des
associations de patients et l'ONG
Médecins du monde étaient invités à
partager leurs points de vue face à
cette situation et si pour eux et bien
le constat de ces pénuries réellement
préoccupant pour les malades la solution
pourrait plutôt venir des brevets
le ministre de la santé doit être en
mesure de multiplier ses sources
d'aprisonnement d'approvisionnement
pardon et déclencher la licence d'office
lorsqu'un brevet est exploité dans des
conditions contraires à l'intérêt de la
santé publique pour répondre aux crises
posées par des prix anormalement élevés
la licence de fils a été mise en place
sous la présidence du général de Gaulle
les gouvernements successives n'ont pas
su ou voulu se saisir de cet outil plus
grave ils n'ont jamais créé les
conditions réglementaires pour faire que
cette option soit même réalisable alors
la licence d'office dans l'intérêt de la
santé publique à laquelle se réfère
Juliana verras de Médecin du Monde est
une disposition du Code de la propriété
intellectuelle permettant aux autorités
l'exploitation d'un brevet par un tiers
sans le consentement du titulaire du
brevet merci Mathias alors sur cette
question du prix Philippe Lamoureux
est-ce qu'effectivement on achète pas
assez cher ces médicaments qu'on a qu'on
dit je crois surtout qu'on mélange un
peu tout si vous me permettez vous avez
cité des des chiffres concernant les
ruptures qui sont en fait les
signalements de risque de rupture et non
pas les ruptures alors sont divisés le
chiffre par 3 pour avoir le chiffre
exactement ce que nous dit l'agence
nationale sécurité de 840 ce sont
rupture et risque de risque de rupture
3700 sont les risques de rupture
deuxième élément ce que je viens
d'entendre de la part de Médecins du
Monde les ruptures portent sur des
produits matures donc des produits dont
les brevets sont échus il y a donc aucun
lien entre la licence de vie et la
problématique des ruptures c'est un abus
de langage d'accord troisième élément je
voudrais revenir sur ce qui a été dit
par votre chroniqueur et parfois des USA
il y a quatre raisons principales à ce
phénomène de rupture le premier point
c'est il y a une explosion de la demande
mondiale 10% par an pourquoi parce que
les pays en développement des pays
émergents comme la Chine l'Inde la
Russie le Brésil se dotent de système de
protection sociale moderne et que ça
crée un appel d'air formidable deuxième
élément c'est vrai une partie de la
production a été délocalisée notamment
en Asie pour les principes actifs
pourquoi parce que ce sont des produits
dans lesquels les coûts de production
sont supérieurs au tarif de
remboursement chez nous en Europe donc
effectivement cette production c'est
délocalisé et elle s'est concentrée de
moins en moins de fournisseurs de
matières premières troisième élément la
guerre en Ukraine la guerre en Ukraine
c'est l'explosion du coût des matières
premières 23% sur l'aluminium et les
délais de livraison mais le médicament
il est appris administré donc on ne peut
pas répercuter sur le prix du produit
l'augmentation des intrants et en 4 et
en 4 les prix alors je suis d'accord je
vais vous étonné je suis d'accord avec
Thomas fantôme je pense que le prix
n'est pas la principale explication du
phénomène de rupture je crois qu'il ne
peut pas lier le phénomène de rupture
avec le phénomène de temps vous nous
dites c'est pas parce que la France
achète ses médicaments trop peu cher que
on est dans une situation plus difficile
que d'autres que la France achète ces
médicaments trop peu cher nous met en
difficulté par rapport à nos concurrents
comme ça a été très bien dit lorsqu'il
faut s'approvisionner sur des produits
en rupture les prix Allemands sont
supérieurs au prix français de 33% les
prix italiens sont supérieurs au prix
français de 18% et quand j'entends le
directeur de lactam cité l'exemple de
l'amoxicile
76 centimes la boîte
donc les coûts de production ne sont pas
couverts par les tarifs à produire pour
beaucoup de produits anciens immatures
ça coûte moins cher à produire en gros
la demande mondiale
construisez des usines est-ce que vous
embauchez à tour de bras pour satisfaire
cette demande mondiale ou est-ce que
vous gérez cette pénurie on augmente les
capacités de production d'ailleurs on
l'a montré au moment du covid la
capacité de production mondiale de
vaccins littéralement explosé mais ça
prend du temps entre le moment où on a
juste les capacités de production et le
moment où on est capable de fournir la
demande mondiale parce que on ne sort
pas une usine de terre en 6 mois ça
prend beaucoup de temps à construire ça
peut beaucoup de temps à être agréé les
autorités dans les différents pays et
donc il va falloir un certain temps pour
s'ajuster et la question et c'est celle
que posait madame la sénatrice c'est
quelle place à l'Europe là dedans on a
un vrai besoin d'une présence plus forte
de l'Europe dans ce qui se joue marche
sur le marché mondial en matière de
production industrielle pharmaceutique
tout ça c'est sympathique mais on n'a
pas beaucoup de levier là-dessus d'abord
je conteste un peu le fait qu'on soit
pris de surprise par la hausse de la
demande cette hausse de la demande elle
était anticipable il y a des évolutions
démographiques qui fait et on est
largement capable à l'échelle mondiale
de répondre à la demande ce qu'il y a
c'est qu'il y a une fragmentation de la
chaîne de production qui s'est
mondialisée pour les raisons qu'on a
évoqué qui fait que dès que vous avez un
problème géopolitique ou de crise
sanitaire ou autre qui coince donc il
faut essayer de rapatrier sur un secteur
géographique un petit peu plus moins
large toutes ces chaînes de production
pour être plus réactif ce que l'on
produit intégralement par exemple en
France comme ça a été le cas pour le dit
pour le paracétamol on est capable
d'augmenter les chaînes de production
mais on va on peut pas tout produire en
France donc ça c'est donc il y a des
causes exogènes mais il y a aussi des
leviers mais oui on peut activer ici en
France c'est peut-être je suis peut-être
excessivement stoïciens mais mais sur
quoi est-ce qu'on peut agir alors juste
pour reprendre les rapports du Sénat en
général d'une exceptionnelle qualité sur
la chose donc c'est pas et je l'ai bien
lu soit de musique mais ce que je dis
c'est que c'est dommage de pas aller à
la cause de la chose c'est il faut
repenser la construction de l'objectif
national de dépenses d'assurance maladie
pour partir justement des besoins et non
pas partir simplement de se dire je fais
un plus deux par rapport à l'année
d'avant et soit chaude bon c'est ça
qu'il faut donc voilà non mais bien sûr
donc ça veut dire que ça veut dire que
finalement la pénurie qu'on vit c'est le
résultat de la crise du système de santé
gros voilà tout ça est lié c'est logique
s'il y avait que le la disponibilité des
produits pharmaceutiques comme problème
bon mais c'est général donc il faut
aussi que le LEM qui est qui est là
s'intéresse à la refonte du système côté
pharmacie parce que si les acteurs ne se
lancent pas et qu'on attend que le
politique nous trouve il y a une part de
responsabilité des entreprises médicales
mais voilà on peut pas dire que certains
acteurs sont des moteurs dans cette
fonte parce que chacun se dit gardons ce
qu'on a au moins on est sûr de de ce
qu'on a sinon on va vers l'inconnu la
deuxième chose quand même c'est que je
suis d'accord sur l'aspect des prix
c'est là c'est la construction des prix
qui est en jeu c'est pas les prix en soi
même s'ils sont un peu plus faibles
qu'ailleurs donc dès que vous avez une
une inflation forte en est plus sensible
parce qu'on a des marges plus faibles en
France mais c'est la construction des
prix quel est le la faille du système
français c'est que d'abord il y a une
espèce d'animosité contre la contre tout
ce qui est innovation je l'ai vu
d'ailleurs que mission certains trouvent
que l'innovation c'est absolument
scandaleux parce que ça coûte cher et
donc il faut combattre l'innovation on a
entendu sur la chose bon c'est une donc
on a cassé depuis 20 ans la capacité en
France de développer de produire
l'innovation bon donc quand on parle de
souveraineté sanitaire c'est qu'on veut
être la Chine de l'Europe on veut être
le pays le plus performant dans la
production à bas coût avec le modèle
social qu'on a oui là on a une
injonction contradictoire qui est fait
donc vive l'innovation que l'État
négocie avec les laboratoires et
toute la latitude pour que les prix
soient raisonnables je dis pas que c'est
simple mais il en a la latitude enfin
encourageons plutôt l'innovation le
problème en France c'est le marché du
générique dans les pays innovants le
marché du générique est en fait au bout
de 10 ans de commercialisation en
général le breveton tombe dans le
domaine grand public et donc votre
produit devient généricable c'est-à-dire
produit
n'importe quel laboratoire peut le
produit d'accord bon et bien en France
on a un marché tout petit du générique
45% à peu près en volume contre plus de
80% en Allemagne plus de 80% et pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui freine et pourquoi il y a
plusieurs raisons mais notamment il y a
l'industrie pharmaceutique des
princesses qui freinent des quatre fers
des princesses c'est à dire des des
molécules qui ne sont pas dans le
domaine générique qui freinent des cas
de fer pour que ces molécules aillent
dans le domaine du générique alors je
dirais c'est c'est je jette pas la
pierre c'est bon non merci
responsable de ça alors on y viendra
après mais d'abord par d'autres
interrompre parce que je
bien que la la parole se voilà se
partagent le mieux possible qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ça non non d'abord
sur les génériques il y a il y a une sur
ce qu'on fait affirmer par où je pense
que je pense que c'est un combat
derrière garde plus personne aujourd'hui
ne
conteste la place du générique pour une
raison très simple c'est que le
générique je permet de de fournir des
économies qui vont permettre de financer
en théorie d'innovation en théorie c'est
vrai et en réalité
je reprends les termes de feuilles
bizarres pardon nous interrompre si la
France est en retard par rapport à
d'autres pays européens pourquoi pour
une raison très simple c'est que c'est
pas parce que l'industrie absolument pas
quand vous regardez les répertoires
alors on va rentrer dans la technique
mais quand vous regardez les répertoires
de générique les répertoires de l'Agence
du Médicament le taux de pénétration du
générique dans les répertoires il est à
85 %. donc le générique comme le bio
similaire à l'hôpital d'ailleurs il a
toute sa place le vrai problème c'est
que il y a effectivement une
particularité française qui la demande
de sécurité des patients sur les
produits qui fait que nous avons une
approche par les autorités santé du
générique qui est un petit peu plus
restrictif que chez nos voisins donc
c'est pas vous sont les autorités de
santé mais pour revenir sur le sujet de
pour revenir sur le sujet qui évoqué
Frédéric bizarre sur le les moyens que
la collectivité concentre au médicaments
parce que ça c'est un sujet absolument
essentiel et il a raison nous parlons
aujourd'hui directeur
d'approvisionnement mais si demain une
commission sénatoriale s'intéresse à
l'accès à l'innovation elle mettra en
exergue la même situation c'est à dire
que rupture d'approvisionnement et accès
de l'innovation patience sont les deux
faces d'une même pièce nous avons je
vais au bout de mon idée nous avons
décapitalisé le médicament de 6
milliards d'euros en 15 ans le
médicament c'était 14% de l'ONDA il y a
15 ans c'est moins de 10% depuis le
dernier PLFSS ce qui m'étonne
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on s'intéresse aux
rupture d'approvisionnement et à l'accès
innovation mais qu'on vote des PLFSS en
contradiction complète avec ces
objectifs sonner la votre avis je reste
moi je suis un peu voilà
sur cette question des génériques du
développement du marché générique en
france de la responsabilité celle de
l'État celle d'éventuellement de
l'industrie financière vous avez vous
avez reçu évidemment les représentants
de l'industrie pharmaceutique je pense
que les sujets qui ont été évoqués sont
réels c'est-à-dire que il y a il y a un
sujet industriel d'arbitrage mais il y a
aussi un sujet de de pilotage et de
choix de l'exécutif sur ces questions là
très clairement et notamment une absence
de transparence sur la négociation du
prix du médicament on a on a
les autorisations de mise sur le marché
qui sont pas tout à fait reproductibles
d'un médicament à l'autre alors qu'on a
le même principe actif on voit bien que
tout ça ce sont des parts de marché de
pénétration des médicaments de sur voilà
sur la prescription et donc on
[Musique]
je pense que une fois encore ce débat
sur le générique c'est un débat qui pour
moi est largement derrière nous
et honnêtement je pense véritablement
que le générique a toute sa part
aujourd'hui et la défiance est une
réalité rappelez-vous il y a quelques
années il y a eu un problème un pseudo
problème de sécurité sur un médicament
générique c'était en fait une erreur de
reconditionnement d'une patiente panique
générale et mise en cause de la
politique du générique dans tout le pays
donc il faut il faut quand même être
très conscient de ça mais pardon je vais
reprendre ce que vous faites plus de
marge sur les génériques non les
produits c'est peut-être pas le produit
que vous avez envie de mettre en avant
mais ce produit mais ce ne sont pas les
mêmes entreprises c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui il faut bien non génial sont
très très rentables pour les
laboratoires donc il y a cette espèce de
ventre mou en fait de sur un plan
économique pour l'élaboratoires dont
tout l'intérêt des laboratoires c'est de
garder ses anciens produits avec des non
génériques avec des batailles juridiques
sur les brevets pour éviter que les
brevets tombent donc on fait des mites
bon ça c'est une réalité on peut mais je
veux dire il faut pas non plus se
cristal le but c'est pas qui est
responsable de ça il y a notre stabilité
j'aurais juste te dire une chose sur la
responsabilité de l'État on voit bien
que quand l'État n'arrive pas à réguler
la maltraitance dans les EHPAD la
maltraitance dans les crèches on voit
l'affaissement de l'État en matière de
régulation et en fait toute le problème
avec l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est un
problème de régulation on est incapable
de réguler cette industrie de de façon
efficiente sur la chose donc c'est ça la
question je pense qu'elle est éminemment
politique je prends juste un exemple
l'organisation institutionnelle de
l'État pour réguler le médicament vous
avez une agence nationale de sécurité le
médicament la NSM dont le rôle est
largement aujourd'hui européen
c'est-à-dire de l'évaluation médicale
mais qui fait quand même tout son
travail d'évaluation médicale puis vous
avez la Haute Autorité de santé qui
reprend tout le travail qui refait le
travail d'évaluation médicale puis une
évaluation médico-économique donc on a
un accès au marché de à peu près 500
jours en France contre à 100 jours
voilà un exemple de faiblesse de l'État
qui peut être réglé par une décision
politique et donc là on est bien sûr une
réorganisation de l'État j'ai parlé du
dispositif de régulation des dépenses
d'assurance maladie qui comprenant le
médicament là sur l'organisation de
l'État mais en fait ça ça n'intéresse
personne franchement on passe des heures
oui enfin un peu le peut être les choses
mais je vous assure que on en parle pas
beaucoup Sonia de la pauvreté vous
l'avez évoqué la question du stylo de
sage en fait
la question du pilotage en fait ça
du budget
qu'on propose au travers de projets loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale pour
la santé à partir d'un objectif qui
s'appelle londam et en réalité enfin moi
je lui dis de façon extrêmement triviale
cette ondame s'est bouché le trou de la
Sécu quoi et donc en fait c'est ça il
sert à ça ce PLFSS dire on a une
médicament une dispositif
médecine de ville et puis quand on veut
mettre un peu sur l'hôpital on prend sur
la ville on prend sur le médicament on
prend c'est comme ça que ça se gère sauf
que c'est un stand qu'on pose pas c'est
une prothèse de hanche qu'on ne pose pas
ou c'est effectivement un médicament
qu'on des rembourse parce que c'est elle
est là en fait la faille du système et
les médicaments des remboursés très
honnêtement sont pas forcément des
médicaments forcément intéressants pour
les laboratoires dans du point de vue
économique et puis je voulais dire aussi
que on a une façon de communiquer en
France sur sur les sujets de santé qui
qui me semble-t-il sont quand même assez
étonnantes on a dit les génériques c'est
pareil mais non c'est pas pareil il y a
une ambiguïté c'est quelque part enfin
moi j'ai connu l'arrivée des génériques
et c'est pas pareil quand on avait un
traitement chronique pour une maladie
chronique depuis fort longtemps et qu'on
remplacer du jour au lendemain le
médicament princeps ce qu'on avait par
un générique qui a pas forcément le
Mexique puis il y a pas forcément la
même forme galénique et qui
artérielles qui ont été déséquilibrées
il y a des antidiabétiques oraux qui
n'étaient pas les mêmes et qu'on a dû on
a du rééquilibrer
les pâtes mais incroyable vous avez une
façon radicale de traiter les questions
et de les balayer du reverdama ce que je
vous dis c'est que dire que c'est
exactement la même chose il faut
et à l'autre on va parler de
d'innovation et on va s'appuyer Mathieu
sur votre chronique on a voulu ensemble
se poser la question de cette promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron la la relocalisation
de paracétamol alors là on n'est pas
dans l'innovation hein
on en est où alors vous souvenez c'était
au lendemain du premier confinement leur
était alors la souveraineté et le 15
juin de 16 juin par an 2020 lors d'une
visite d'un site de Sanofi à
Marcy-l'Étoile près des près de Lyon et
bien le président annoncé ça regardez
tout le monde a vu durant cette crise
que des médicaments qui paraissaient
usuels n'étaient plus produits en France
et en Europe
tout le monde l'a vu
et donc nous devons au-delà de nous
poser la question en tirer toutes les
conséquences on pourra par exemple
pleinement reproduire
conditionner et distribuer du
paracétamol en France
il nous faut retrouver la capacité à
faire cela
il faut dire que durant le début de
l'épidémie en tout cas les autorités
sanitaires avaient été contraintes de
rationner les achats de paracétamol une
hérésie pour beaucoup de Français parce
qu'on rappelle que c'est le médicament
le plus vendu dans le pays plus de 500
millions de doses chaque année ça
représente à lui seul le paracétamol 22%
en volume je crois du marché du
médicament
ce qui est quand même absolument énorme
alors dans la foulée de l'engagement
présidentiel Olivier Véran qui était
leur milieu de la santé Agnès qui
s'occupait d'industrie annoncé même dans
un communiqué commun pardon que d'ici
trois ans donc on est en 2020 la France
serait en mesure de reproduire
conditionner et distribuer du
paracétamol maison bon bah les trois ans
c'est dans deux mois et il faut
reconnaître que on n'y est pas encore et
vous allez nous expliquer pourquoi parce
que rédiger un communiqué de presse ça
prend 10 minutes mais relancer une
filière de production on en parlait tout
à l'heure ça prend évidemment du temps
faut savoir qu'en France pour l'instant
il existe des usines qui conditionnent
qui façonnent qui conditionne le
paracétamol mais qui ne fabrique pas ce
qu'on appelle le principe actif on en
parlait tout à l'heure c'est à dire la
molécule chimique en gros que la
dernière à le faire a fermé en 2008 et
du coup on est dépendant des
approvisionnements dont on parlait de
Chine ou d'Inde alors il y a un projet
qui a été lancé depuis la crise covid le
groupe pharmaceutique séquence a décidé
de relancer la production de paracétamol
sur le sol français le site a été choisi
j'allais dire pas par hasard ça se sur
la plateforme chimique de Roussillon
dans l'Isère exactement là où se
produisait la dernière usine qui a fermé
qui produit une race du paracétamol en
2008 mais les premiers livraisons de de
produits donc de paracétamol français ne
devrait pas arriver avant fin 2025
pallier au financement c'est pas lié à
l'argent non c'est pas un problème
d'argent parce que des financements
étaient trouvés à grand renfort de
subventions publiques 30 à 40% à la fois
de subvention et d'avance il a fallu
mais le problème c'est que on peut pas
non plus faire n'importe quoi parce
qu'il a fallu trouver d'abord je disais
un processus de production qui soit
moins polent que ce qu'on tolérait il y
a quelques années parce que mon polo en
CO2 moins évidemment la société
française a pris conscience aussi que
l'usine chimique c'est différent il faut
une enquête publique faut toute une
série d'autorisation un avis positif de
l'Agence du médicament et tout ça ça
prend du temps mais à terme en tout cas
le site devrait produire près de 10000
tonnes de paracétamol ce qui couvrirait
toute la demande française et même un
tiers des besoins européens je crois bon
en attendant on a connu encore des
pénuries cet hiver oui alors notamment
de Paris pédiatrique mais aussi certains
de paracétamol pour adultes et la
particularité c'est alors selon les
industriels ce ne serait pas un problème
de production mais de consommation c'est
ce qu'on disait en tout cas Sanofi ou
ipsa qui a trois mois expliquait que
leurs usines tournaient à plein régime
pour des niveaux de production record en
hausse de 50% chacune alors certains
critiques les industriels en disant oui
mais fallait vous y prendre avant les
gars vous avez pas anticipé vous nous
parlez de grippe de gastro de
bronchiolite mais c'est des maladies
saisonnière et vous n'avez pas fait en
temps réel et puis les industriels
répondent toujours ben on a aussi
beaucoup de contraintes bref mais la
vérité c'est qu'on est tous responsable
d'une certaine façon parce qu'on disait
il y a la fois les médecins qu'on
prescrivent peut-être trop les Français
qui en consomment trop puis en plus
quand on leur parle de pénurie qui font
des stocks voilà quand mettre plein
plein les armoires ce qui aggrave parce
que voilà quand ils font des provisions
voilà c'est donc une responsabilité
collective alors est-ce que la réponse
politique d'Emmanuel Macron qui viendra
tardivement être une bonne réponse parce
que ça coûte beaucoup d'argent public
sur un produit qui rapporte peu cette
clé c'est pour ça que je voudrais
finalement la thématique de l'innovation
je veux bien vous donner la parole
là-dessus Philipp Plein moi est-ce que
finalement c'est c'est là-dessus qu'il
fallait investir tant d'argent je pense
que d'abord sur le point que que vous
évoquiez Frédéric Brizard vous a donné
la réponse tout à l'heure nous avons un
problème de gouvernance de la politique
du médicament c'est-à-dire que il y a
effectivement
des programmes extrêmement volontaristes
qui ont été menées au plan industriel
pour relocaliser de la production on
parle beaucoup de l'exemple du
paracétamol en réalité il y a une
quinzaine de projets qui sont
aujourd'hui soutenus et celles qui sont
un stade relativement avancé on peut
considérer que c'est pas suffisant bien
sûr mais en tout cas il y a une certaine
dynamique qui a été enclenché la
difficulté c'est je repose ma question
pardon nous interrompre c'est pas très
agréable mais est-ce qu'il faut mieux
mettre cet argent pour pour produire du
paracétamol parce qu'au contraire il
faut mettre cet argent pour innover et
trouver de nouveaux faire les deux en
réalité il faut faire les deux et faire
des choix et je viens sur mon point la
difficulté que nous avons en France
c'est une espèce de forme de
schizophrénie administrative qui est que
ce que fait le ministère de l'Industrie
d'un côté n'est pas cohérent avec ce que
fait le ministère de la Santé de l'autre
et Frédéric bizar le disait très bien si
je prends l'exemple du ministère de la
Santé moi j'ai au ministère de la Santé
aujourd'hui 10 interlocuteurs différents
quand vous avez 10 interlocuteurs
différents je suis désolé de le dire
c'est une machine à organiser la non
décision et donc si vous avez d'un côté
la volonté de porter une politique
industrielle il faut préserver voir
Créer parfois un marché et si de l'autre
côté vous avez des politiques de
régulation qui détruisent votre propre
marché vous ne pouvez pas attirer
l'investissement industriels et en
réalité il faut faire les deux il faut
savoir que alors je ne suis pas un grand
fervant de la souveraineté je pense que
je préfère le concept d'autonomie
stratégique il faut renforcer
l'autonomie stratégique de l'Europe mais
nous sommes une industrie mondialisée et
on était très contents d'aller chercher
les traitements de sédation en Corée ou
en Thaïlande au moment du covid pour les
amener en France c'est ça qui nous a
permis de passer le cap donc renforcer
l'autonomie et en même temps
effectivement réussir à attirer la
production des médicaments innovants il
faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de
grands laboratoires innovants cherchent
des sites de backup en Europe et il y a
un marché industriel de l'insplantation
de produits de backup mais si comme on
le disait vous mettez 500 jours arrivés
sur le marché vous avez pris le plus bas
d'Europe vous n'investissez pas en
France alors moi ce que je retiens sous
l'été on va terminer là-dessus nous
rester 3 minutes c'est sur le pilotage
10 interlocuteurs différents je vous
donne la parole juste après faire 10
interlocuteurs différents au mystère de
la santé c'est enfin c'est pas possible
on a à tel point c'était tellement
compliqué à gérer que pendant la crise
coït on en a rajouté une couche pour
avoir une tasse forte et pour avoir
[Musique]
de PIB il faut quand même pour finir sur
une seconde positive on est dans une
phase d'abondance d'innovation
pharmaceutique avec des de l'innovation
technologique absolument extraordinaire
venant de plusieurs révolutions donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut investir dans les
produits matures ou est-ce qu'ils font
investir dans ces technologies là est-ce
que la France est un pays historique de
recherche d'ingénieurs ou est-ce que la
France est un pays de production vous
voyez bon je crois qu'on a la réponse
est dans la question et et là on sentait
malheureusement l'argent public est rare
et donc on perd du temps et si on veut
d'ici 2030 revenir à peu près dans le
wagon de tête des pays innovants et moi
je suis convaincu que qu'on n'y est
capable il faut vraiment urgemment
changer de stratégie et de politique de
santé merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je rappelle
le titre de votre livre Frédéric bizarre
l'autonomie solidaire en santé la seule
réforme possible qui est publiée aux
éditions
Michalon voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission je vous dis à demain 18h et 22h
sur public Sénat et puis noter que
l'invité politique Dorian Mancini dans
la matinale ce sera Alexis Corbière le
vice-président du groupe la France
insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale belle
soirée
[Musique]